je joue mon nouveau spectacle sur scène
le spectacle de la maturité à la cigale
de paris à partir de décembre en plus
dans toutes les villes du monde comme
lyon marseille lille dijon
bon j'ai pas tout le dire c'est écrit
sur l'écran j'ai trop hâte de vous y
voir prenez vos places dans la
description
bonjour ouais je suis pas tout à fait
chez moi je suis dans un studio que vous
reconnaissez peut-être perdu sur la
chaîne de bigorre dans les coquillages
je me suis littéralement accaparé en
fait ce studio le temps une petite vidéo
parce qu'en fait mon propre décor j'ai
un nouveau décor qui est en train d'être
construit en ce moment en tout cas merci
les mecs de me prêter ce très beau lieu
bref bonjour à tous comme vous l'avez
compris sans doute dans le titre de
cette vidéo je lance officiellement mon
nouveau spectacle mon deuxième spectacle
sur scène je montre affiche d'ailleurs
ouais les normes ouais en fait elle est
à la taille de mon ego c'est à dire
surdimensionné
le spectacle de la maturité voilà
j'avais ici de manière ultra commercial
j'avais fait un premier spectacle qui
s'appelait norman sur scène vous aviez t
400 milles à venir le voir c'est un
chiffre énorme estime merci encore pour
ça ça c'est mon deuxième
le spectacle de la maturité tout est
nouveau c'est vraiment la suite du
premier donc que du neuf
ça fait deux ans que je le peaufine
quasiment tous les soirs sur scène va
donc je suis vraiment très heureux et
très fier d'enfin vous le présenter
d'ailleurs sans plus attendre voici un
petit extrait de ce spectacle a tourné
durant un entraînement en public
évidemment au paname une ovation pour
norman s'il vous plaît
thank you save en quoi c'est une vraie
ambiance est cool moi je compte en est
là mon prénom c'est norman à norman fait
des vidéos sur youtube peut-être que
certains connaissent je sais pas voilà
un gros succès comme ça comme je fais un
gros spectacle qui a cartonné un
meilleur spectacle 2017 selon le
graphique mois à la page fait diffuser
sur youtube j'ai 2 milliard de vues sur
youtube
ouais c'est ça ouais et c'est quand je
vois quand j'ai aussi gros chiffres des
fois j'ai un peu peur de prendre la
grosse tête tu vois heureusement les
gens sont là en permanence au quotidien
sur twitter je me rappelais que je fais
une grosse merde à chaque fois que je
m'excuse twitter jeu directement
contredit paul simplement écrit
bonne journée à tous un mec a répondu au
g20 martinique c'est plutôt bonne nuit
fils de [ __ ] ou à la fin de la phrase
c'est pas obliger les gens sont sans
pitié sur les réseaux [ __ ] forme toof
même surtout des fois je vois ce
commentaire mec t'as vidéo elle est cool
mais romancé à 5 minutes trente mois
tout content je regardais 1,5030 celle à
la fin de la vidéo
les gens imaginent pas que derrière
l'écran il ya un humain tu vois qui peut
prendre du xanax et quand je vois toute
cette haine sur la zone puis chargement
est avec vous ce soir sur scène au moins
vous vous n'avez pas de deux micros et
bien dans la rue parfois les gens
viennent me voir tu vois une dispute à
norman g métro tilt ou quand j'étais
petit mec t'as neuf ans
ces petits donc alors qu'est ce que je
raconte dans ce spectacle je raconte la
vie au delà de youtube
notre époque ma génération mon bébé ma
copine mon chat un tour du monde
la nuisance des réseaux sociaux la
technologie tous ces petits riens du
quotidien qui nous concerne tous et
plein plein d'autres trucs mais je vais
pas tout dire ici en tout cas c'est pas
du tout un spectacle autocentrée sur moi
ça parle vraiment de nous tous vous là
dedans et moi précision ce spectacle
s'adresse à toutes les tranches d'âge je
dis parce que souvent on pose la
question et ouais c'est quoi ta cible
il n'y a pas de cible moi j'ai 32 ans
j'écris mes délires au feeling donc
évidemment les adultes vont comprendre
les subtilités et les ados vont capter
aussi et en même temps les enfants
s'ennuieront jamais parce que j'ai tout
pensé pour alors c'est pas un spectacle
écrit à la va vite
l'histoire de remplir des salles et se
faire un délire dans le stand up c'est
ma passion je fais ça depuis six ans
maintenant et vous le savez je monte sur
scène quasiment tous les soirs avec le
trac avec le mal de byd parfois je me
suis pris des beats justement parfois
c'était génial j'ai galéré si je me suis
autant accroché c'est parce que vraiment
c'est ma passion ma vocation
je monte sur scène comme un artiste
qu'est ce que je fais c'est artistique
donc quand vous viendrez me voir vous
comprendrez que ce que je donne sur
scène c'est vraiment le le meilleur du
meilleur de ce que je peux vous raconter
et que j'ai peaufiné pendant plus de
deux ans si vous avez aimé vidéo vous
aimerez ce nouveau spectacle si vous
avez aimé mon premier spectacle vous
aimerez encore plus ce second spectacle
je vous le garantis c'est du stand-up à
100% donc c'est moi sur scène avec un
micro qui raconte des trucs marrants
pendant une heure avec aussi des
surprises et un peu de musique et où il
ya beaucoup d'écriture mais aussi un peu
d'impro y aura à chaque fois des
premières parties de potes à moi très
cool que vous connaissez peut-être en
stand-up mais aussi peut-être en musique
et en magie ce spectacle c'est mon petit
bébé mon petit projet artistique à moi
que je peaufine depuis si longtemps
j'en suis très très fier donc si vous
pouvez mettre un maximum de l'ail de
commentaire partager la vidéo en parler
autour de vous j'espère qu'il vous
plaira autant que le premier merci merci
du fond du coeur je vous aime énormément
d'ailleurs petit cadeau je vous offre à
vous qui regardez cette vidéo 50 places
de spectacles répartis dans 25 dates
différentes partout en france on va
répartir un peu il y aura tirage au sort
si vous vous laissez place gratuite et
vous suffit d'écrire un commentaire la
phrase suivante
je veux des place pour ton nouveau
spectacle
voilà j'ai bossé l'eau enfin je précise
ce spectacle ne sera pas sur youtube
il existe uniquement sur scène donc vous
n'êtes pas j'ai très très très hâte de
vous voir ou de vous revoir le lien pour
prendre directement vos places et dans
la description et je vous conseille de
vous dépêcher parce que les places par
très très vite
mon père n'a déjà acheté quatre voies ça
par exemple c'est le blagueur a pas dans
ce spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]